[Music]
hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about the Starks some of the final
season holds for them supportive it
leaked photos trailer teasers and of
course a few theories and predictions of
mine by the word Starks I mean brain
arias ensign of course John who is both
a Stark in the Targaryen with the
arrival of Jon Snow and the crew at
Winterfell the stark family will finally
be fully reunited their ancestral home
Jon's lament Danny with their entire
Cruiser can only headed north to prepare
for the Great War that is coming even
sooner than expected they're sailing
towards white Harbor the main seaport of
the north did the unsullied once they
arrived over there they'll meet the
track in the Kings Road and then ride
together to NFL of course solo this will
likely take place of screen and we'll
probably only see all of them together
approaching Winterfell in the very
beginning of the first episode here we
can see Arya falling in line with Danish
dragons as they are flying towards
Winterfell
one genre is a man FL he'll have a heart
breaking uranium in his family with
sensory and brain as well as his friends
and his Darvill ghost out of folder
Indians John sensor Union is the first
that's been officially confirmed to take
place in the season 8 premiere with the
season 8 first look teaser image we got
to see a clip of Jerry netting Lisa
Tsering Lady of Winterfell Sansa the
reason of sense a glaring origin
shoulder turned out to be Danny
having in mind that Sansa back in the
second episode of the seventh season
said that Danny does want to help the
north but rather wants to concrete
manifester likely to assume that Starks
sisters including the other northern
Lords will not accept Danny as good as
John did but we might be wrong yes there
will be some tension between sense and a
knee until census is versa who the
initial is and what a true intention is
however there will be no intense moment
between Ari and Danny in fact I think
that the Indian Arya will get along very
well considering how both of them admire
and respect strong and powerful women
also since is passionate about her
gearing history and they can dragon
riding sister wife says seen in season
two with his any Targaryen being her
harine we can imagine she's predisposed
to like and be fascinated by Danny
and her dragon see season 8 which this
clip seems to be suggesting everyone is
the fear of such beasts flying above
them but Arya Stark is happy to finally
see one well - in fact and soon have the
third one as well
the reunion were the most excited about
this duranium between John and Arya Arya
and John have not seen each other since
season 1 when they had close sibling
relationship and they just missed each
other in season 7 which frustrated many
fans still think John be the least one
of his sister is promising and if he is
reuniting with Sansa he'll also see and
reunite with Arya well it's easy to say
that John will be proud but also blown
away by how much harder has grown as a
fighter it's also safe to say that aria
unlike Sansa will support John decision
no bending the knee to the dragon queen
in fact I think that Danian Arya will
get along very well considering how both
of them admire and respect strong and
powerful women enemies beside reuniting
me just though I also expect Arya to
reunite with time area as well at some
point of the final season most likely in
episode 3 it has already been confirmed
that we'll see more of the d'Urbervilles
in the final season meaning not only of
goes but of course the Nymeria both
there are the only dolls whose stories
are not over yet
and they'll definitely have a role to
play in the final six episodes
Nymeria might appear with a pack of
wolves in episode 3 during the battle
from NFL and come to Stark Center
brother's ghost aid or maybe Tori's
rescue after reuniting with his sister
general Serena the brain brain is beside
Howland Reed and same the only person
who knows Joshua lineage and is the only
living man who actually witnessed John's
birth even though he's been waiting the
whole season to revealed to John the
truth I don't think he will reveal it
adjourn at the first meeting and I don't
think he'll be the one to reveal to him
at all an actor who plays cent is
disabled his character in season 8 Sam
is really feeling the responsibility of
this information but he knows Jon would
rather hear this from Sam than anyone
else is this a confirmation that Sam
will be the one to reveal John the truth
or did he just say that to throw us away
you decide Brandon same together
discover the truth but then we'll
probably be a better messenger given
brand's detachment from his family and
weird behavior ever since he became the
three-eyed raven and
actor who plays Brent is this about his
character we see a slightly visor brain
this year who's less like Roberto Burle
oh that's great to hear
but still the tool probably agree that
it's battery center livers this breaking
news to John and this clip seems to be
in that exact moment John and Samuel
siege shattered for the very first time
since John was killed and resurrected
Sam will probably be the one to reveal
to John his show parentage but Howland
will likely finally appear in the
current timeline and confirmed these
same statements to John with some
evidence it's also possible that Sam
might proclaim Jonah's were high I hear
that was reborn amid smokin salt a hero
the tool will the flaming sword to stare
against the others than if he falls the
world falls venom in the season 7
premiere the show point now that the
book Gilly picked up and began reading
was a book about the long night but the
exact part she was reading was about the
prophecy of azor Ahai already made a
video regarding which character might be
this prophesied Savior
but John son of Ice and Fire seems more
and more to be the Lord's Chosen anyways
upon finding out about Joshua parentage
in season 7 which basically affirms that
he's the Song of Ice and Fire and upon
finding out about John's death and
resurrection the final season it's quite
possible that Sam will proclaim Jana's
were high I also believe that the book
about long night that Gil was reading in
season 7 premiere will resurface in the
final season which would likely lead st.
once again as brain if he is able to
look back in time but it's time even
beyond into the past to see what exactly
happened last time the White Walkers
came for the living this is how brain
will play a huge role in the final
season as he will help John and Danny
strategize for their first fight against
the night king and his army of the Dead
this will most probably involve quite a
few flashbacks where we would learn a
bit more about the White Walkers Center
motivation now that all the Starks have
reunited then they're finally on the
same place it's time for John to rina
faith ghost as well it's been confirmed
that goes to finally return in season 8
let's hope he doesn't die in the battle
for Minerva
the Starks sister will also renate with
hound which is going to be very nice and
since the Veloster Rena IV Tyrion
there's one more character arriving in
Vener fell with John and Danny it's game
check hole finally reunited Arya
the two spent a lot of time together in
earlier seasons and both have grown to
like and deeply care for one another
they'll be happy to see one another
alignment now perhaps the reunion might
even give us a hint at gangees fighters
promised or inspire in season one might
finally be fulfilled King Robert was
talking about Joffrey who he thought was
his son and a daughter Sansa however
this never happened and therefore how
stark and Baratheon have not been joined
yet
however huge amount of fans believe that
this marriage might finally happen in
the form of Roberts only son country in
Ned's daughter Arya what do we know for
a fact is that the two will reunite in
the final season and it's going to be
very interesting to see how their
relationship will play out before the
battle against the night King that is
set to take place in the third episode
the image the Starks will be the Fanning
manor fell the Starks will have one more
important reunion is the one with Jaime
Lannister Jaime's arrival at Winterfell
was firstly teased by the official
season 8 photos very so Jaime in stark
armor that by the way looks exactly like
Rob's sitting in a room dead judging by
the type of the walnut background seems
to be located and men are felled and
then the trailer confronted Jaime will
indeed arrive at Winterfell likely in
episode 1 ending or episode 2 beginning
and he will also fight for very elegant
and acting in his army bran will
renovate the man who tried to kill him
because he saw him having an intimate
relationship with his sister obviously
we don't expect from Starks to execute
Jaime for this after all John Solomon
then invited the Lannisters to come and
support the living in the worse to come
Jaime agreed and done in this pledge
meaning that no harm would John do to
him nor would he allow anyone else to do
so Starks turn at the phrase that's not
a way
brain will likely forgive Jaime and the
song probably say brains live in episode
3 during battle for NFL kit harington
teased about his character Jon Snow the
end of the world might be coming soon
but at least he's in love with somebody
he knows who is and then comes a
sledgehammer his parentage available be
a huge blow to John and his relationship
with Danny and it's unsurprising a
sledgehammer to Jon will likely come
from rain or even more likely from Sam
once John learns he's a Targaryen which
basically means he and Danny are related
as Rhaegar is his father in Dana's
Rhaegar sister the other news will hit
him Dane is carrying his child it has
been highlighted numerous times during
season 7 that Dany believes she can no
longer have children because of a
prophecy that was told to her by
was during season one finale even though
Danny does believe in this prophecy is
just not pointing out himself it may not
be entirely true
additionally so many people have talked
about Daly's ability to help children in
so many things that it seems like John
and Danny having a baby's not even
questionable but was rather foreshadowed
how I see John learning this is through
Danny of course and probably in the
crypts of NFL we don't have many stark
leagues from episode three except
Ferrari and John fighting fiercely for
their home and something like the death
stark resurrected by the night king from
the cribs chasing Arya to the course of
NFL but I guess we don't really need
many leaks the night king is attacking
NFL and Starks start defending it all I
hope is that Johnny not only will fight
alongside their Darrell's ghost in the
media and the DA rules don't actually
end up sacrificing themselves for their
masters what we do know however is the
winter will not fall if in FL this
battle will be a huge defeat for the
Sharks and the living all the same then
FL is on fire the Nike is one but don't
worry
the Starks did most of the main
character so survive as you might expect
this battle will leave many dead check
out this image of lifeless bodies strewn
across the ground outside the Winterfell
set and money glass which is just one of
a bunch so the Starks survived the most
dangerous place to be in episode three
and to place the tag by 100,000 strong
army of the Dead led by the 19 and then
in episode 4 one of them which is Jon
Snow of course goes to the second most
dangerous place place ruled by Cersei
Lannister Jon Snow will come back to
King's Landing in Episode four sir st.
John Snow meet one-on-one in King's
Landing
well not exactly one on one as Cersei
has the mountain and Queen's Guard
around it Shan coming to plead with
Cersei and once again answer to provide
a me troops or is it trying to commit
Cersei to let them all in to make their
final standing is landing there are many
possibilities
speaking of Jon it's also very likely
that he will write a dragon named after
his father Vega in the trailer we see
Jon in the any approaching Joe Kinnear a
go
we know Danny is obviously headed to
ride Jorgen and seemingly John is headed
to ride the other one many fans have
been wondering how will Jon react to the
fact that he's a tag Aryan will he be
fighting for House Targaryen or House
Stark the question which was in fact
already answered by Jon Snow in season 7
Jon Seto Theon you don't have to choose
your stark in your Greyjoy
Johnny's the targaryen in Stark there's
Lowell Toonami know about the Starks
whereabouts after episode three sophie
turner who played sense that is that
sense of the season is very much
enjoying becoming a leader in their own
right and this year there's certain
challenges by people who threaten that
given what we have seen so far and what
information we have received this
conflict will firstly be be Danny a
sense of and not accept her as good as
Jean did or as good as are evil there
will be some tension between them in the
first episode or two but it could also
mean that sense I might also make a move
against her biggest enemies Cersei
Lannister you'll see as Ferrari amazed
William stays there's this play at Aria
between trying to be who she wants to be
getting back to back to that naivete and
innocence for her family and her
unfinished business what it means is the
target will stick with her family and
fight for Winterfell against the night
king in Episode three but when man fell
for salmon Aria learns of sources yet
another betrayal over her family she'll
have to say a temporary goodbye to her
family and go to finish Harrington's
list there's a high possibility that
area will shell to King's Landing to put
an end to Cersei or at least a try
regarding the Starks endgame brain in
general obviously be crucial in stopping
the night king brain with his visions
and Jon actually fighting the night king
I believe all the Starks will survive
game thrones which I'm probably ruling
Westeros at the end together be Danny
brain is the three-eyed Raven since they
will probably end up at Winterfell as
its lady renovate it and rule it after
the Great War is over a safari will
expect her to either die in a battle or
to live out her days as an assassin
adventure and that's what probably need
of this will happen it will be too
predictable her again happy ending and
living her life as a proper lady she
never wanted to be will be a huge twist
or I'll most likely end up married Genji
and live out her day is raising their
children in a castle I have a son you
have a daughter will join her houses is
the quote that's always been on my mind
while snog was killed in season one
which set of the events for the serious
I cannot help but think that Ned did for
share of this marriage when he told Arya
that she will marry a high Lord and rule
his castle just as Robert wanted back in
the first season the houses Baratheon
and Stark will probably join three son
and his daughter just not to the ones
here Ned thought their heavy guy is the
fate of House Stark in final season of
Game of Thrones if I missed something
please let me know in the comment
section and of course let me know your
thoughts of
13 said in this video and as always I
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see in the next
one peace